Okay. Well, it's time to lock in. The
market is seriously moving this morning.
Uh 15minute chart of NASDAQ. We're
coming up to basically I think that's
pretty much all-time highs. ES is not
quite there, but it's a previous high.
And then
um also we have oil here is doing a
pretty big selloff
kind of just back down to this kind of
support area. Um so I like it for a
bounce off this big move down. Uh I
would like a double bottom though to
some extent. It does have news
right here.
Um, so
we'll see if that sets something up.
Mainly, honestly, what I'm looking at is
this NASDAQ
move right now is pretty crazy. Um,
we've got news at 8.
Not big news, honestly. Uh, the 8:30 is
oil. These are, you know, not West Coast
times. Then FOMC
is in in a while. So, this move will be
done by then.
Um, so I just want to see if it kind of
looks like it's going to reverse here at
kind of 45 or 8 a.m. kind of quick early
morning reversal.
See what happens.
Just going to quickly let my room know
what I'm thinking.
I would prefer a five minute but like
big picture this is a nice
spot. I really like
that we are at the alltime highs here.
It is a lot of movement strength. I mean
this is broken
but the main thing is that there's
the fair value gap is basically saying
hey it's super overextended.
It's super overextended into sorry
smaller chart into that previous high.
I mean, even a pullback down to like
here somewhere is great.
It's 54.
This news coming out is
let's see pull up this
tool I have. Let's see. It's a wholesale
inventories. So at
top of the hour wholesale inventories
is not a big release. So it shouldn't
really matter that much and I can
actually trade through the release.
Um so that's kind of important to know.
If this sets up beforehand, I can pretty
much say I'll just get in anyway.
So I might enter in the ES instead.
This move back up a lot more. Which one
is up?
So NASDAQ is up.8 this morning while the
ES is up6.
So it's definitely moving more,
but I would I would I would like to
trade the weaker one.
because that's generally the better way
to go.
We got a little bit more of a pullback
than this.
Um, two minutes on the news.
That's right there.
just trying to take
I do want to fulls size this actually
because this is a really nice move
at a good area.
Um
gold actually looks strong. This is gold
on a 15minute. Gold looks like it's
going to bottom
and it's somehow showing strength when
the market is showing strength and so
I think that's kind of helpful for this.
Okay, news is popping up after this
candlestick here.
Um, oil is still kind of doing its
thing. I'm not really concerned about
that right now. I'd rather focus on
this.
Comparing these two, still
NASDAQ is showing
still more strength while the ES is
showing more weakness.
I do want to be aware that this could
just pull back and shoot continue to
shoot higher. But
again, I want to be aware that that's
okay.
I still want to jump in when a good
signal shows up because
um it's at a good area that makes sense.
You know, I don't know what the market's
going to do. Obviously, I just want to
jump in when it makes sense.
like this is a nice little stab higher.
ENQ's actually making a new high. Wow.
While ES is not.
So, I think if
NQ looks like it's going to fail,
that's what I want to jump in on.
like this if this fails
like putting in an order below this low
because on a five minute I think that
would still look pretty good on a five
minute
because also big picture if I pull up
targets for this potential.
I mean, it's the the easy money would be
giving this move back up, but then we
could push lower to here, which would be
like this is 3x. This would be like 6x.
Um,
which would be obviously a sick move.
I don't think that's super likely, but
Wow. So, that does look good.
I do want to get in short if it but
All right. Like, I think I want to get
short here.
It's just a little nerve-wracking with
the NQ being.
But again, like that was a fast move up.
So, I'm nervous about this. But again,
the reasons to get in are good.
NASDAQ,
it could have just got, you know, this
could just be like a final push higher
that fails.
This candlestick right here is pretty
strong. It's just a
an attempt in a new high and then it's
gonna fail.
I would like to see how this does this
kind of bottom here and then continue
higher,
but I think if the NASDAQ gives up, this
is going to push lower.
So, I think I'm going to put in an order
below this.
It's a good setup. New high, lower high.
Big picture is good.
And I'm going to put my stop above the
highs
and I'm going to manage
accordingly.
Um,
nice failure there. Again, like the big
thing is this could just come down and
bottom and continue higher.
So,
this point. Just kind of let it do its
thing.
See how it plays out again like this
looking even on a five minute. That's a
nice fivem minute candle.
Um
but we'll see what it does.
Oh, puppy.
Okay, I think this is not going to work
cuz let's be honest, your trades never
work.
But it looks good. It looks good in all
reality.
That's a nice little poke hire.
Um, let's look at what
gold looks good.
Pray the gold goes up. That'll help.
Oil.
I don't like oil for I suck at oil
longs, honestly.
And when I look at it, this is just I
think FOMO over seeing this move. really
the sick entry was this bar right here
and catch that move down otherwise it
was just not worth it.
Um, so I mean like if it bounces, but
it's got it's got news in 20 minutes, so
unlikely.
Again, it's pretty nerve-wracking
cuz there could be just a lot of
strength here and it could just
uh
continue up.
But again, the main thing is it's all
about just following your plan because
this doesn't have to work in every time.
Even if it works 50% of the time and I
get 2x or a little bit off one, like
it's great.
And this still is setting up.
It's still at a decision point. Not out
of the woods, but I think ES looks good.
I'm going to sit on a five minute.
See what that looks like.
I'm going to move it. It's It was not in
a good spot to be frank.
The reason why I like it to be above the
high because if the market came up here
and like let's say
reversed
right here, knocked me out, but then did
a big bar down, I would still want to be
in, but I would have been out of the
trade. Like, it's not violated until it
breaks up here.
It can come up here and then do a failed
breakout back, failed selloff back in,
but usually that's unlikely.
So, this
is not selling off quickly. I would say
it doesn't look good.
I think if this
lower high here on the NASDAQ doesn't
turn into a head and shoulders and start
going down, I'm going to want to get out
cuz at that point, it just looks like
it's probably going to continue higher.
I'm just going to go step away for a
while because this is driving me a
little crazy
and I think it's going to not work out
even though NQ is actually making more
lows.
NQ looks better
than the ES now. But
this trading, we got to sit here in the
agony
of indecision.
I think because of it being kind of like
this once it gets to break even or 1x I
think I'm going to go break even
unless it just gets moving quickly.
This is when just looking at a a bigger
picture five minute chart just makes it
way easier to
to drown out the noise.
of it
looking good or or looking bad.
We're just looking for a push. Of
course, the NASDAQ is now selling off
better.
Classic. You choose one and the other is
better. Um,
now I'll just turn this on to for kicks.
I want to move to break even now because
if it just shoots up after that, I'm
just going to get out. Like, just get me
out of that. Um, I'm going to take off
2x for sure
down here. If it just blips lower.
Yeah, just that's a nice start. It could
totally just reverse up after that
though.
Would it suck to just get out
at break even? Yeah,
after all that. But
as a part of trading,
all right, we're I'm looking for this
move. It has stabbed through most of
this
move already, which is kind of rough.
But I can also if it starts to slow
down, I'll trail a little bit. Like I'll
trail previous candlestick.
I'm just going to give it a minute here
and see.
Got to manage my stupid recording pages.
Okay, I'm going to trail with two
with the previous candlestick.
That looks like it's just going to
basically not get knocked out.
O,
I really want to pull this down.
It literally just almost blipped it.
[Applause]
Okay, it filled that. My computer is
literally lagging.
Okay, I'm moving the rest down here.
to 2x.
I want to give it some room, but also
like
I'm not going to give it, you know,
crazy room here.
There we go. That's fine room right
there.
I'm going to give it I'm going to give
it this candlestick because it's clearly
ENQ hasn't even given the move back up.
Big picture. Pulling up the 15minute
chart again just to see where we're at.
Again, the easy money is kind of over.
But I don't So, and so it's like I'm
giving it some room, but also like I'm
not going to give it like one, you know,
a crazy amount. Like this is the move
I'm really looking for. I'm not really
looking for this. Like that's more if it
just rips lower,
you know?
[Applause]
Sick trade
that just came out of nowhere. I was not
expecting that to happen after this
chop. I was like, I'm screwed. I've lost
for the day.
Um
well, okay.